der 23 juni 2016 ein Datum das in die
Geschichte eingegangen ist an diesem Tag
stimmten 51,9 % der Briten für den
Austritt aus der Europäischen Union die
Trennung war bestätigt worden der brexit
würde Realität werden was dann natürlich
auch passiert ist aber wisst ihr
eigentlich noch was die hauptversprechen
der Pro brexit-kampagne waren nun es gab
viele aber dieses eine war bei weitem
eines der wichtigsten und
entscheidendstendorf
Aktivisten behaupten der brexit ist der
einzige Weg die Einwanderung unter
Kontrolle zu bekommen wie ihr sehen
könnt zeigten die Umfragen vor dem
Referendum man eindeutiges Ergebnis die
große Mehrheit der dritten ob sie nun
brexit Befürworter waren oder nicht
glaubte dass der BR eines der britischen
Regierung ermöglichen würde die volle
Kontrolle über ihre Grenzen
zurückzuerlangen und damit die riesige
Zahl von Einwanderern die ins Land kamen
zu reduzieren der brexit brachte viele
Dinge mit sich aber aus wahltaktischer
Sicht ging es vor allem um die Kontrolle
der Einwanderung sowie deren
Auswirkungen auf das Gesundheitssystem
die Schulen den Arbeitsmarkt und das
tägliche Leben der britischen
Bevölkerung seither sind nicht weniger
als sieben lange Jahre vergangen und die
Frage die wir uns nun stellen können
lautet welche Auswirkungen genau hatte
der brexit eigentlich auf die
Einwanderung hat er seine Versprechen
diesbezüglich wirklich gehalten nun ja
liebe visualpolitik Community die Daten
sprechen eine eindeutige Sprache 24
November 2022 Einwanderung nach
Großbritannien verdreifacht sich trotz
brexit versprechen Achter juli 2023
Migranten Überfahrten über den
Ärmelkanal erreichen 9 Tages Rekord für
2023 die Einwanderungsdebatte ist zu
einem der zentralen Themen in Downing
Street number ten geworden
obwohl Großbritannien seine Grenzen
jetzt wieder ganz eigenständig
kontrollieren kann hat der Zustrom von
Einwanderern nicht nur nicht abgenommen
sondern sogar zugenommen und das obwohl
die wirtschaftliche Lage des Landes
nicht besonders rosig ist die Frage die
wir uns stellen lautet also inwieweit
ist das Vereinigte Königreich zu einem
Land geworden das offen für Einwanderung
ist was ist aus einem der größten
Versprechen des brexit geworden wusstet
ihr eigentlich dass Richie Sonax Team
hofft die Einwanderung oder besser
gesagt den Kampf gegen die Einwanderung
zu einem großen Wahlkampf Thema im
Vorfeld der nächsten Wahlen im Jahr 2025
zu machen nun in diesem Video erfahrt
ihr alles Wichtige über die riesige
Einwanderungswelle die das Vereinigte
Königreich überrollt lass uns aber
vorher noch einen wichtigen werbe
Hinweis unseres tollen Sponsor surfshark
einspielen damit wir danach sofort
fahren können denn wusstet ihr dass
viele Firmen wie z.B Airlines ganz
unterschiedliche Preise anbieten können
je nachdem von welchem Land aus man
bestellt bzw ein Ticket Bucht aber zum
Glück kann man solche
diskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe eines
zu überlisten und richtig Geld sparen
und Social VPN ist ein wirklich
empfehlenswertes weil er sicheres VPN
welches zum Beispiel keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit lockt eine Virtual
Private Networks VPN ist aber nicht nur
zum Geld sparen geeignet nein es kann
einen auch vor so mancher größeren
Gefahr schützen die im Netz lauert
natürlich muss man nach wie vor um sich
walten lassen und wissen was man tut
aber es stellt hierfür ein Werkzeug mit
gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwert ist in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen oder Aktion im Netz
nachverfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheit könnt ihr so
eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen z.B mit
dem integrierten klimap das alle
unerwünschen Cookies blockt weiterer
Vorteil eines dass ihr wie gesagt zu tun
könnt als während ihr an einem anderen
Ort so könnt ihr nicht nur billigere
Tickets buchen sondern z.B auch auf
Webseite und Internetdienste zugreifen
nebeneinander Seiten verfügbar wäre noch
dahin oder im Urlaub damit schlagt ihr
dann auch Zen so und hier blocking ein
Schnäppchen Netflix und anderes
anbieten von Europa oder deutsches
Internet fernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
surfshark kein Problem aber das ist doch
lange nicht alles denn mit nur einem
Konto könnt ihr wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte im VPN registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode politik.de
angeht bekommt ihr von softshark auch
noch eine Rabatt in Höhe von 83% und
oben dran die ersten drei Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nicht viel los besorgt euch
damit gleichzeitig uns finanziell unter
die Arme das könnte übrigens auch direkt
mit Hilfe des Spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die Videobeschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dankbar denn damit hättet
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
nun lasst es aufbrechen auf die Insel
die gerade von Migranten überrannt wird
aufgepasst
[Musik]
öffnet die Tore
meine Lieben Zuschauer es ist unmöglich
über Großbritannien nach dem brexit zu
sprechen ohne Alexander Boris day favel
Johnson zu erwähnen ihr wisst schon
Boris Johnson ja derselbe Typ der
Journalisten morgens Tee anbietet mitten
am Tag mit einem Regenschirm kämpft und
die Kinder während der nachbetäglichen
Rugby Spiele besänftigt kurz gesagt eine
der schönsten und umstrittensten
Persönlichkeiten der modernen Politik
über die wir sogar mehrere Videos
gedreht haben ich werde sie euch
natürlich verlinken damit ihr sie
nachher noch genießen könnt aber Johnson
waren nichts Geringeres als eine der
größten Befürworter und Förderer des
brexit tatsächlich war er wahrscheinlich
der Rang höchste konservative Politiker
der diese Position vertraut und ja als
gründe dafür nannte Johnson auch
Einwanderung und Grenzkontrolle aber sie
selbst für mich ist diese quatschen
on the moment
immer wieder betont das ein verbleibt in
der Europäischen Union bedeutet jegliche
Kontrolle über die Grenzen aufzugeben es
schadet dem Vertrauen der Bevölkerung in
die Demokratie zutiefst das britische
Politiker der Öffentlichkeit jedes Jahr
erzählen sie könnten die Einwanderung um
10.000 reduzieren und dann feststellen
dass sie ihre Ziele um Hunderttausende
verfehlen Boris Johnson im Mai 2016 das
soll nicht heißen dass Johnson eine
Anführer der Anti immigrationsbewegung
war oder pauschale etwas gegen Ausländer
hätte er war bloß nicht einverstanden
mit der unkontrollierten Einwanderung
von jährlich hunderttausenden von
Menschen denn gleichzeitig sagte auch
Dinge wie diese Boris Johnson sagt eine
geringe Einwanderung konnte zu
wirtschaftlicher Stagnation führen zu
dieser Zeit war Johnson Bürgermeister
von London und obwohl bereits damals
klar war das sein Ziel die Downing
streamen bei ten war musste er sich
damals noch eine Weile gedulden nach dem
Rücktritt David camerance der sich für
den Verbleib in der Europäischen Union
eingesetzt hatte übernahm seine
Außenminister
[Musik]
aber may versagte bei den Verhandlungen
zum brexit kläglich und mit ihren
Rücktritt kann der zerzauste Blowjob
Johnson im Juli 2019 endlich an jenes
Zepter der Macht von dem er schon sein
ganzes Leben geträumt hatte er wurde der
Regierungschef Großbritanniens eines der
ersten Dinge die er als neuer britischer
Premierminister in angriffnahme war
genau die Migrationsfrage und nach viel
Arbeit legte seine Regierung im März
2021 einen neuen Plan für die
Einwanderungspolitik vor ein Plan der
Ende Juni 2021 als Gesetzesentwurf im
Unterhaus vorgelegt und im April 2020
verabschiedet wurde wir werden gleich
einen genauen Blick darauf werfen
ihr müsst nämlich wissen seit fast einem
jahrzehn ist die britische Politik
gerade zu besessen von diesem Thema
berücksichtigt man allerdings den Zuzug
von Ausländern so hat sich in Johnsons
Amtszeit nicht viel geändert außer dass
die Zuwanderung noch stärker angestiegen
ist wir können uns zum Beispiel ansehen
was mit den Flüchtlingszahlen passiert
ist wie ihr sehen könnt haben die
britischen Behörden 2019 70% mehr
Asylanträge genehmigt und nach der
Pandemie stiegen diese Zahlen sogar noch
weiter an und das ist nur ein Beispiel
denn die Wahrheit ist dass auch die Zahl
der arbeitswieser seit Johnsons antritt
in die Höhe gestellt ist im Jahr 2022
wurden fast 70% mehr erteilt als 2016 im
Jahr das brexit Referendums überzeugt
euch selbst es stellt sich also die
Frage was um Himmels willen passiert ist
ging es beim brexit nicht eigentlich
darum die Einwanderung zu begrenzen war
Johnson nicht ein starker Befürworter
von Grenzkontrollen ist das Vereinigte
Königreich unter der konservativen
Tutorial Regierung zu einem Vorreiter
der Willkommenskultur einer Politik der
offenen Tore geworden nun nachdem wir
die Fragen gestellt haben lasst uns zu
den Antworten kommen
[Musik]
man will immer das was man gerade nicht
hat
Großbritannien hat wie der Rest Europas
einen großen Bedarf an jungen
Arbeitskräften das liegt zum einen daran
dass die Bevölkerung im älter wird zum
anderen aber auch daran dass die
Unternehmen sehr unterschiedliche
Jobprofile benötigen von gering
Qualifizierten Jobs mit sehr niedriger
Wertschöpfung die die Briten einfach
nicht mehr machen wollen bis hin zu hoch
spezialisierten Fachkräften die für die
modernsten Branchen unerlässlich sind
z.B für die Technologiebranche oder für
die sehr wichtige britische
Finanzindustrie als Johnson also in der
Downing Street number ten ankam stand er
folgenden Widerspruch gegenüber
einerseits sollte er die brexit
Versprechen erfüllen und eine Reform
vorliegen die Verordnung sorgt ohne
Zuzug von außer wenn reduziert
andererseits sollte diese Reform aber
der nationalen Wirtschaft nicht im Wege
stehen und die Frage ist was denkt ihr
was passiert ist nun wir haben es ja
bereits gesehen die Daten lassen uns
keinen Raum für Zweifel
und wisst ihr was besonders seltsam ist
nun dass all dies Johnsons Beliebtheit
nicht sonderlich beeinträchtigt hat
plötzlich wurde von einem so prominenten
und wichtigen Thema das in Austritt aus
der Europäischen Union zur Folge hatte
ein nun ja ein nothing Burger also etwas
was eigentlich keine Sau mehr
interessiert tatsächlich ist laut einer
Studie des ist natürlich am Kings
College landen die Ablehnung der Briten
gegenüber ausländischen Arbeitskräften
seit dem brexit sogar eingebrochen
interessanterweise steht dieser Trend in
krassen Gegensatz zu Ländern wie
Australien oder Kanada das ist doch
paradox oder nach dem Austritt aus der
Europäischen Union scheint die Briten
also plötzlich viel offener und
aufgeschlossener geworden zu sein und
das obwohl das Hauptmotor des pro brexit
Lagers gerade darin bestand den Zustrom
von außen zu stoppen und drastisch zu
reduzieren und das ist ja genau das
Gegenteil von dem was gerade passiert
und was noch merkwürdiger ist darüber
hinaus hat er Anstieg der Einwanderung
wie das Ansehen der Regierung
beeinträchtigt noch schade irgendwie
verärger t darüber zu sein und was daran
noch besonders interessant ist die
Ablehnung von Einwanderern ist in allen
Altersgruppen stark zurückgegangen egal
ob Generation sie Millennials Baby
Boomer oder die vorkriegsgeneration bei
letzterer hat sich die Ablehnung in den
letzten Jahren sogar mehr als halbiert
und liegt mittlerweile nur noch bei 8%.
die absolut logische Frage lautet also
war warum eigentlich nun wahrscheinlich
aus diesem Grund
[Musik]
obwohl die britische Wirtschaft momentan
nicht gerade eine Blütezeit erlebt ist
die Arbeitslosenquote sehr niedrig und
in vielen Berufen herrscht ein großer
Arbeitskräfte Mangel und dass man eben
Zuschauer bekommen die Briten hautnah zu
spüren es erklärt zum Beispiel warum sie
laut einer aktuellen Apps aus Umfrage
gerne mehr Ärzte Krankenschwestern und
sogar Landwirte ins Land holen würden
tatsächlich wünschen sich nur weniger
als 20% der dritten eine Verringerung
des Zustroms und Fachkräften und das
sind praktisch jeder Branche
interessanterweise sind Bankangestellte
die einzige Ausnahme aber seien wir
ehrlich der Auslöser dieser bankophobie
sind wohl eher die Banken als die Bank
Angestellten und das ist noch nicht
alles dieselbe ist das um Fragezeichen
das 46% der dritten die Auswirkungen der
Einwanderung als positiv bewerten
gegenüber 29% die sie eher negativ sehen
und selbst diese negative Wahrnehmung
nimmt merkwürdigerweise genau seit 2016
steht dich ab mit anderen Worten jetzt
wo viele mehr Einwanderer ins Land
strömen sind die Briten plötzlich nicht
mehr beunruhig darüber natürlich muss
man dabei aber zwischen der britischen
Öffentlichkeit und den britischen
Politikern differenzieren die derzeitige
konservative Regierung hat eine Reform
des Einwanderungsrecht voran die so
umstritten ist dass sie sogar vor dem
Europäischen Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte landen musste na wollt
ihr wissen wovon ich spreche nun lasst
uns darauf noch mal einen genauen Blick
werfen
[Musik]
Spiel mit dem Feuer
so wie es aussieht interessiert die
Briten das Thema Einwanderung nicht mehr
sonderlich aber gleichzeitig
beschäftigen sich die Politiker immer
noch sehr intensiv damit im April 2022
gelang ist der johnson-regierung ihren
neuen einwanderungsplan zu verabschieden
so wurde mit dem neuen Gesetz
beispielsweise ein zweistufiges System
eingeführt das Flüchtlingen je nach
einreiseweg in das Vereinigte Königreich
unterschiedliche Schutzniveaus Boot all
jene die über sichere und legale Wege
einreisen erhielten eine bedingungslose
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung aber andere die
irreguläre einreisesten Kunden nur eine
vorübergehende Genehmigung für 30 Monate
beantragen und das war noch nicht alles
die Reform sah auch vor der britischen
Marine die Kontrolle über die Hoheit
Gewässer des Ärmelkanal zu erteilen und
sie in diesem Zuge auch für die
Kontrolle der Einwanderung über diese
Route zuständig zu machen darüber hinaus
enthielt der Plan eine Alternative wenn
Sie diesen Weg einschlagen wenn Sie den
Ärmelkanal illegal in den Boden
überqueren riskieren Sie nicht in
Vereinigten Königreich sondern in Ruanda
zu landen ja ihr habt richtig gehört um
die illegale Einwanderung zu bekämpfen
schloss die Regierung Johnson ein
Abkommen mit Ruanda das kleine
zentralafrikanische Land sollte einfach
alle Einwanderer aufnehmen die von
Großbritannien nicht akzeptiert wurden
[Musik]
im Grunde genommen bedeutet das dass die
britischen Behörden alle Menschen deren
Anträge abgelehnt wurden die als nicht
förderungswillig eingestuft wurden oder
die sich illegal im Land auf hielten
nach Ruanda abschieben wollte der erste
Flug im Rahmen dieses neuen
massenabschiebungsplans war für den 14
Juni 2022 geplant musste aber nach einem
unterlassungsurteil des Europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte
ausgesetzt werden da die britische
Reform gegen mehrere internationale
Konventionen zu verstoßen Schienen
außerdem gibt es ernsthafte Zweifel
daran dass es sich bei dieser
Alternative um die beste Option handelt
woran das Vergangenheit bei der Aufnahme
von abgeschobenen gibt anders zu Sorge
über ein mögliches britisches Programm
von den schätzungsweise 4000 Menschen
die Israel zwischen 2014 und 2017 im
Rahmen eines Programms zur freiwilligen
Ausreise nach Ruanda und Uganda
abgeschoben hat sollen fast alle das
Land sofort wieder verlassen haben wobei
viele versuchten über schleuserroten
nach Europa zurückzukehren auch die
Erfahrung Australien ist das seit Jahren
einen ganz ähnlichen Ansatz mit
illegalen Einwanderern verfolgt haben
scharfe Kritik und sehr viele Zweifel
hervorgerufen genau die Insel auf der
Kinder ihren Lebenswillen verloren haben
wir haben begonnen selbst mörderisches
Verhalten bei Kindern im Alter von 8 bis
10 Jahren zu beobachten sagt Louis
Newman eine Professorin für Psychiatrie
an der Universität von Melbourne
Australien die mit Familien und Kindern
auf der Insel arbeitet tatsache ist dass
die britische Regierungskrisen erst
unter Boris Johnson und dann unterlist
Trust die Ruanda alternative gestoppt
haben doch trotz aller Kritik können wir
sagen dass Johnson noch eine
einigermaßen aufgeschlossene Position
vertragen zumindest wenn man sie mit der
aktuellen Situation vergleichen denn in
London sitzt ja schon wieder eine neue
Regierung und wisst ihr was rieson
Aktien hat sich in eine große
parlamentarische Schlacht gestürzt um
seine eigene Reform desselben Gesetzes
voranzutreiben es bereits vor etwas mehr
als einem Jahr aufgeistert
johnson-regierung geändert worden war
wohlgemerkt es ist immer noch dieselbe
Partei die Tories an der Macht
[Musik]
was daran wirklich merkwürdig ist trotz
der Tatsache dass die britische
Ablehnung der Einreise von Einwanderern
Flüchtlingen drastisch gesunken ist will
sunax Regierung Johnsons Gesetz
verschärfen dieses Gesetz ermöglicht es
zum Beispiel Flüchtlingen die auf ihre
gulären Wege ins Land kamen ein
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung für 30 Monate zu
erhalten jetzt will die britische
Regierung durchsetzen dass alle Personen
die irregulär einreisen weder eine
Genehmigung noch einen Aufenthaltsstatus
erhalten nicht einmal den Status als
Asylbewerber zuna Bilder mit
sicherstellen dass weder Flüchtlinge
noch ihre Kinder ein
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung bekommen wenn sie
irregulär einreisen das bedeutet dass
sie unabhängig von ihrem Status
inhaftiert und abgeschoben werden der
Gesetzentwurf wird den Umgang mit
Menschen die illegal über sichere Länder
in das Vereinigte Königreich einreisen
grundlegend verändern indem ihre Asyl
und menschenrechtsansprüche in Bezug auf
ihr Heimatland und zulässig werden und
der Innenminister verpflichtet wird sie
abzuschieben tja das bedeutet im Grunde
die Abschaffung des Konzepts des
politischen Asyls Großbritannien wäre
dann kein mögliches Ziel für Menschen
die gezwungen sind ihr Land so schnell
wie möglich zu verlassen weil sie dort
verfolgt werden es stimmt zwar dass die
illegale Einwanderung ein Nährboden für
Betrug ist aber wenn das Leben oder die
Freiheit als Menschen in unmittelbarer
Gefahr sind zum Beispiel wegen seiner
politischen Ansichten oder weil er die
Demokratie verteidigt wird er in vielen
Situationen in seinem Land keine
bürokratischen Verfahren durchlaufen
können die Jahre dauern zu naag
berücksichtigt dieses Problem nicht das
ist einer der Hauptkritikpunkte an
diesen politischen Fahrplan der wie ihr
sehen könnt sehr viel strenger ist als
johnsons-reform um das ganze mal in den
richtigen Kontext zu setzen die Zahlen
liegen in Großbritannien sowieso schon
weit unter denen eines klassischen
pullerndes wie Deutschland während auf
der Insel im Jahr 2022 noch rund 74.000
Personen Asylanträge stellten waren es
in Deutschland ganze Zeit
244.000 also mehr als dreimal so viele
augenfällig ist auch dass der Anteil der
ankündigen im Königreich die die
asylkriterien am Ende gar nicht erfüllen
auch nicht so groß ist
23.800 haben 2022 Asyl erhalten während
es in Deutschland 41000 waren das heißt
in Großbritannien kommen im Vergleich zu
Deutschland auch so schon viel weniger
Migranten an die keinen wirklichen
Flüchtlinge sind gut new Germany waren
es 2022 nämlich viermal so viele aus
deutscher Sicht handelt es sich bei den
britischen Zuständen also quasi um
Luxusprobleme diaman auf hohem Niveau
aber wartet das ist noch nicht alles
denn jetzt kommt es besonders hart
die sunackregierung hat noch eine drauf
gesetzt und den Ruanda Deal bereits
offizielle gemacht obwohl Umfragen
zufolge die Mehrheit der Briten dagegen
ist Ziel dieser Vereinbarung ist es für
Asylbewerber deren Anträge von
Großbritannien nicht geprüft werden
einen umsiedlungsmechanismus nach Ruanda
so schaffen dass ihre Anträge bearbeiten
und die Personen nach der Entscheidung
über den Antrag entweder aufnehmen oder
abschieben wird Absichtserklärung
zwischen der Regierung woanders und der
Regierung des Vereinigten Königreichs so
stellt sich also die große Frage wenn
die britische Öffentlichkeit anscheinend
kein so großes Problem mehr mit
Einwanderung hat und gegen die
Abschiebung von Menschen nach Juanda ist
wozu dient dann diese politische
Aktionismus nun vor allem einem Zweck
Kommunalwahlen vom 6 mai 2023
leberpartei überholt die Konservativen
als stärkste Partei in der
Kommunalverwaltung die Pandemie Johnson
stürzt die List trust-krise die
exorbitante Inflation steigende Zinsen
der Zustand der Wirtschaft die
konservative Partei befindet sich in
einer schweren stimmungskrise
[Musik]
wie ihr dieser Grafik entnehmen könnt
sind die Umfragen eindeutig für die
nächste Wahl im Jahr 2025 scheint die
Labour-Partei derzeit der klare Favorit
zu sein und die Frage die euch jetzt
vielleicht stellt lautet welche Rolle
spielt die Einwanderung bei alldem nun
im Grunde deutet alles darauf hin dass
die Solar Regierung die Einwanderung
wieder zu einem ihrer zentralen
wahlkampf-themen machen will mit anderen
Worten obwohl es keinen wirklich mehr
interessiert will sie dieses Thema mit
aller Macht wieder ins Rampenlicht
drücken um Härte und Stärke
demonstrieren zu können das hat für die
Konservativen in der Vergangenheit gut
funktioniert weshalb sie es jetzt
offensichtlich wieder damit versuchen
wollen und genau darum verbreiten sie
besonders harte Botschaften und
verabschieden absolute Initiativen wie
zum Beispiel ist ein sperren illegaler
Einwanderer auf einem riesigen Boot die
7 August 2023 Großbritannien beginnt mit
der Inhaftierung von Migranten auf einem
Lastkahn den Feuerwehrleute als
Todesfalle bezeichnen oder Sie machen
Ankündigungen wie diese hier sind
ich meine das ganze in ein
adverbekampagne zu verwandeln scheint
nicht der beste Weg zu sein mit dem
Problem der Einwanderung umzugehen oder
was meint ihr nun natürlich Zielen die
Konservativen damit in wesentlichen auf
Flüchtlinge und illegale Einwanderer ab
denn wenn es darauf ankommt wird das
Vereinigte Königreich wahrscheinlich
weiterhin so viele Arbeitsgenehmigungen
ausstellen wie bisher warum nur eines
feststeht die britische Wirtschaft wird
auch in Zukunft viele neue Arbeitskräfte
brauchen mit anderen Worten abgesehen
von der Frage wie wichtig ist ist
illegale Einwanderung zu verhindern oder
ob das britische einwanderungssystem
verbesserungswürdig ist hin viele den
Verdacht dass die jüngsten
Gesetzesänderungen in erster Linie Wahl
taktische Gründe haben könnten bei all
den Problemen die das Vereinigte
Königreich momentan Beuteln scheint die
Migration nämlich Sinne sinnvolle
Priorität zu sein und aus diesem Grund
meine Lieben Zuschauer werden wir sowohl
am Thema wie man einwanderungs sinnvoll
gestaltet als auch an den Problemen der
Post brexit-insel dranbleiben vergesst
also bitte nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen
falls auch euch diese Themen
interessieren und ihr sie nicht
verpassen wollt und wenn ihr das
erledigt habt ist erstmal eure Meinung
gefragt was hattet ihr von Sonax
politischen Fahrplan wärt ihr in eurem
Land mit Abschiebungen nach Ruanda
einverstanden was haltet ihr von solchen
Initiativen wie sollte man eurer Meinung
nach Einwanderung in eurem Land steuern
und gestalten wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem interessanten Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt es bitte ein Like als mit
neuen Freunden und diskutiertes auch mit
ihnen natürlich wollen wir doch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
Mädel dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]